where do you find this at you may not
like the movie but I'm wet you guys want
me to blush and don't you hello everyone
I'm here at BuzzFeed to read my thirst
tweets I'm
[Music]
curious Jas M MOA should win an Oscar
for making me
horny I would literally throw myself
down a flight of stairs fight a tiger
and spend eternity in the depths of hell
for a chance to lick the fish scales off
of Jason Mo's ABS God damn I want to
ever see Jason Mamo clean all right
there we go there's a nice one I want to
always see him grungy looking like the
phermones are strong and wearing a
belt I don't stink I mean the Fons are
strong um I get the wearing Pelt thing I
enjoy it too all I'm saying is my day is
never made worse by seeing Jason with
Mo's naked but oh
thanks I mean all I'm saying is Jason M
could throw me through three layers of
drywall drywall it would be totally okay
it's very imaginative I've never really
thrown anyone through one wall of
drywall Chason Mamoa confuses me because
I don't want to have sex with him but
would sell an organ to have him hold me
while I smelled his
hair I did not ask to see Jason M's ass
cheeks on the timeline today but I'm not
that upset man's is Caked Up I'm afraid
okay Jason Mima Emoji heart heart heart
heart I want to be his submissive house
husband oh I don't have one of them so
you're at the top of the list I bet way
more people would go to see Aquaman if
they just called it wet Jason mamaa okay
fun fact about Aquaman every time Jason
mimo's wet so am I from Dirty Mike and
the boys Jason Mo mimo you want a new
dog well I can bark with you want a new
motorbike we'll jump on because vom
vroom anything you want I can be cool uh
there are altogether too many superhero
movies and most of them are bad but you
can't stop me from paying a American
dollars to see wet Jason Mamoa in a
theater I mean that's the log line for
Aquaman isn't it you may not like the
movie but I'm wet in your theater come
to see Aquaman 2o my sexual preference
is Jason Mamoa with a blush pink
scrunchie all right Jason Mo can crushed
my head with his thighs like a walnut
honestly truly yo I just went down a
Jason Mamoa rabbit hole and I have
questions how and why is that man so
fine how and why I'm trying to find his
parents cuz I need to know how they made
that perfect mix of a man you guys want
me to blush don't you I'm a lesbian but
I totally let Jason M Mo get me pregnant
emoji with a face I wouldn't even be mad
if he left me right after LOL if you
don't think this man is attractive I'm
just going to assume you're a hater
LOL Jason Mamoa can glance at me and my
legs will be wobbling panties
soaked sometimes I wonder why straight
men will simp for a girl just cuz she
looks good there's more to women than
just that and honestly I think that
objectifying them like that is so
immature on a completely unrelated note
I want Jason moo to sit on
me I would definitely let Jason MOA
throw up on me and soak it in myum myum
how do you say that and my yum J M makes
my busy throb sorry busy huh all right
busy throb thank you everyone Mahalo new
law I'm flattered thank you BuzzFeed for
embarrassing me and uh make sure to see
Aquaman the lost kingdom it's out
[Music]
now